So, ich bin noch mal kurzzeitig am Start, Stunde Zeit habe ich noch oder eineinhalb
Stunden Zeit habe ich noch, so habe ich mir gedacht ich mache einfach mal Streams so an.
Wobei, warte mal, ich wollte doch eigentlich mit dem Fabian heute irgendwas machen, ne?
Ist der da?
Okay.
Ich wollte, wann war denn der zuletzt da?
Ah, hier.
Ich wollte mit dem Fabian noch irgendwas machen heute, was war das denn nochmal?
Ah, das habe ich vergessen.
Achso, mein Video-Account umziehen, genau, null.
Werde ich wahrscheinlich eh nicht mal spielen, aber schadet wahrscheinlich auch nichts,
ne?
Ehe noch keiner da, ich laber jetzt hier quasi komplett ins Leere.
So fühlt man sich wahrscheinlich als einer von 99% der Twitch-Streamer, wo irgendwie
nur null oder der Vorschau-Rechner zuguckt.
Das tut mir ja teilweise auch ein bisschen leid, muss ich sagen, ne?
Ich scroll abends manchmal auf dem Handy durch so Spiele, wo halt sonst auch kaum einer unterwegs
ist und gucke dann durch, da gibt es echt seitenweise Leute, da guckt einfach niemand
zu.
Also mittlerweile ist es so voll auf Twitch, wenn du nicht von irgendwo her einen anderen
Boost kriegst, ist das wirklich verdammt lange und harte Arbeit.
Da irgendwie, und der passende Content selbstverständlich, ne?
Das zähle ich mal unter Arbeit dabei, da was auf die Reihe zu kriegen.
Glück gehört natürlich auch ein bisschen dazu, keine Frage, aber ja.
Das ist nicht mehr wie 2010 YouTube, wo du einfach nur das richtige Game zeigen musstest,
das instant 50k plus.
Nein, 2010 war es eher 5k plus, da war das schon viel.
Mein letztes, ach guck mal, der Twitch hat es kapiert, das ist on, nice.
Ihr seid ja am Start schon Leute, 17 Monate, Dankeschön, hypersubscription.
Oh, die Modes sind vielleicht ein bisschen thick.
Ne, der letzte Stream, den habe ich gelöscht, da war Musik in ein paar Videos drin, die
ich geguckt habe und man weiß auf Twitch leider nicht so genau.
Okay, die Playlist gefällt mir nicht, ich muss mal was anderes machen.
Auch mal irgendwas anderes.
Ja, okay, besser, besser als nichts.
Sag mal, weiß noch irgendjemand?
Ich wollte mir bei Amazon, warte mal, vielleicht habe ich das hier sogar schon in den Warenkorb
reingelegt, oh, da habe ich noch ganz viel drin liegen.
Du klingst nicht gut, ne?
Nö, nö, nö, ist alles in Ordnung.
Hör ich mich irgendwie anders an?
Stimmt irgendwas nicht?
Moment.
Säck, Säck, Säck.
Blablabla, Test, Test, Test, Test, wie höre ich mich an?
Blablabla, Test, Test, Test, wie höre ich mich an, wie immer.
Übrigens, eins muss ich sagen, was die ganze YouTube und Streaming-Geschichte gebracht hat,
ist, normalerweise hat man ja so den Reflex, wenn man seine eigene Stimme aufgenommen
hört, denkt man, man klingt komisch.
Aber ich muss sagen, seitdem ich so viele Videos Probe gehört habe von mir und so viele Stunden
von meinem eigenen Content angeguckt habe, ist das für mich wie ein zweiter Max.
Also quasi, ich höre mich einmal, wenn ich rede und einmal so wie ich in Videos klinge.
Also, das fällt mir überhaupt nicht mehr auf.
So, ich wollte doch mal gucken, irgendwas wollte ich mir noch letztens kaufen und ich
glaube, das brauche ich unbedingt, was ist das für ein, Moment, das da.
Ja, genau, das da, das da wollte ich mir kaufen.
Lackierte, exzellent, lackierte Kabels wollte ich mir kaufen.
Ja, genau, genau, das muss ich unbedingt gerade mal hier nebenbei auf dem zweiten Rechner,
Amazon.
Da bin ich nämlich echt gespannt drauf, ob das was taucht.
Das ist normal, das ist normal, aber glaub mir, du gewöhnst dich danach nicht allzu langer
Zeit dran.
Hallo Max, ich kenne dich seit ich 14 bin.
Na gut, dann bist du jetzt wahrscheinlich, vielleicht bist du 24 oder so.
Ah, okay, schreibt es ja auch dahinter.
23, freue mich, wenn ich manchmal Zeit habe, deine YouTube Videos zu gucken, auch wenn
ich nicht so oft mit dem Informat...
Das hast du heute als Kommentar schon geschrieben oder zumindest jemand hat ein relativ ähnliches
Kommentar geschrieben.
Übrigens, schön, dass du dann mich hierher gefunden hast.
Also du bist nicht der einzige, aber ich mache ja auch noch ein paar Gaming bezogene
Videos.
Aber eins muss man halt echt sagen, ich habe es letztens hier auf Twitter geschrieben.
Das ist, also die Zeiten haben, übrigens drüben im Wohnzimmer liegt was Dickes hinterm
Fernseher.
Ich habe Chico entdeckt, die, wie sagt man, so rumgechillt hat hinterm Fernseher und kam
sich dann ganz ertappt vor.
Aber ich habe es ja letztens hier geschrieben auf Twitter, guck mal wie sehr sich die Zeiten
ändern.
Beliebtestes Video innerhalb der ersten 24 Stunden ist das Video, wo ich über Teilzeit
rede.
Und das unbeliebteste Video war das letzte Battlefield 6 Video.
Schon geil.
Früher wäre das komplett umgedreht gewesen, aber komplett.
Sebaro, der Cute-Mod ist da, Leute.
Wir brauchen eine Runde Ayaya-Spam in den Chat.
Der Sebaro muss sich hier von Weeps umgeben fühlen, dass er öfters, öfters vorbeiguckt.
Ja, nice.
Das ist richtig, Venice hat ja gar keine Spieler mehr.
Venice ist ja voll vorbei.
Aber Venice hat es verkackt.
Die haben das voll verkackt.
Die hätten eins, zwei offizielle Server machen müssen mit gutem Ruleset plus Mod-Spezialitäten
zum Beispiel.
Aber jetzt nichts total abgedrehtes, so Sachen wie Medics können Engineer-Waffen verwenden
oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung.
Dass man aber weiß, worauf man sich einlässt und das gut moderiert ist, dann hätte es
auch geklappt, zumindest mit ein paar Spielern, weil es spielt, zumindest ich finde, es hat
sich viel angenehmer gespielt als Vanilla.
Warum klingt man auf einer Aufnahme anders, als wenn man sich selbst hört?
Naja, weil wenn du dich auf einer Aufnahme hörst, ist das, was aus deinem Mund rauskommt,
ins Mikrofon geht.
Und was du selbst hörst, ist ja normalerweise nur Schall, der entweder aus deinem Mund rausgeht,
von der Wand abgeprallt wird oder hauptsächlich hörst du dich ja über irgendwelche Schall,
oder Knochenübertragungen und sonst was, hörst du dich ja selbst.
Das klingt halt ganz anders.
Würdest du lieber nur Twitch oder nur, oh das ist eine schwierige Frage.
Würdest du lieber nur Twitch machen oder nur YouTube, wenn du eins dürftest?
Okay, also ich gehe mal davon aus, mit irgendeiner Antwort, so wie Multistream oder so, kann
ich mich nicht davor drücken, dass ich einfach sag, gerne stream ich auf eine Plattform,
die auf alle beiden Plattformen weiter streamt.
Also wenn ich nur Twitch oder nur YouTube machen würde, wenn man mal die finanzielle
Art, wenn man mal das finanzielle außen vor lässt, würde ich sagen, würde ich lieber
Twitch machen.
Weil, weil nur hier haben wir den Hi IQ Chat, den gibt es auf YouTube, nur zum Teil.
Der Chat hier ist Massify IQ LittleShana, der ist, der ist durch die Decke, also man
muss sagen, ich habe eindeutig den big-brainigsten Twitch Chat, den es auf Twitch gibt.
Hast du schon mal was von NA Vision?
Ja, NA Vision kenne ich.
NA Vision ist das, die denken, dass das Georgian oder das Georgia und Georgian das gleiche
sind.
Nee, aber NA Vision oder so kenne ich nicht.
Nee, Vision habe ich ja nie gehört.
Doch, doch, so lange schon, ja.
Ab nächstem Monat muss ich, oh, das ist gut, das ist gut, huge brain.
Telefonsupport ist ja auch, also Mail-Support, Support Sachen über Mail beantworten, also
wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, würde ich das noch lieber machen, weil mit Leuten telefonieren
ist schlimm.
Ich muss euch mal was erzählen, ich habe auf der Arbeit so eine dumme Durchwahl, ich
kann euch jetzt nicht genau sagen, welche, aber ich habe so eine blöde Durchwahl, die
ist relativ ähnlich zu der Durchwahl für so eine Abrechnungsstelle für einen Außendienst,
und manchmal verwählen die sich und rufen bei mir an und ihr könnt euch vorstellen,
wenn der Außendienst bei einer Abrechnungsstelle anruft, dann sind die angepisst, weil ihre
Abrechnung nicht stimmt.
Da kommen die immer bei mir raus und sagen, ja, also hören sie mal, ich habe da eine
Frage zu meiner Abrechnung, wie kann das sein, also Moment, Moment, ich, also ich kann ihnen
nicht helfen, ich weiß nicht, um was es geht, sie sind komplett falsch, manche regen sich
da noch auf, da habe ich schon immer, da habe ich immer schon Spaß dran.
Auch nice, exzellent, wo sich wieder bestätigt, viel Twitch bei mir gucken, einfach Massive
IQ easy Übernahme, da gibt es sicherlich noch genug, aber die riesen, diese riesen
Mengen an Leuten, die dann durch die Innenstadt gerannt sind und alle nur auf ihr Handy geguckt
haben, die haben ja damals sogar gewarnt davor, so nach dem Motto, Achtung Autofahrer, Pokemon
Go Spieler laufen vor das Auto.
Ist natürlich nicht was von Microsoft Dynamics, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist, so etwas
wie Microsoft, das sieht so eine Mischung aus, wie als hätte man Exzellent mit SAP gekreuzt,
was ist das denn, wer macht denn sowas freiwillig, ja das, das kann ein bisschen dauern, wobei
man sagen muss, deswegen verwende ich auch Manjaro, weil der Installer easy ist, also
nicht für Kacknoobs, für Kacknoobs ist ja schon der Ubuntu Installer zu kompliziert,
der Windows Installer auch, was arbeitest du, ich arbeite als DevOps Engineer bei einer
Bank in Frankfurt und falls du das genau wissen willst, hier habe ich ein Video zugemacht,
kannst du über YouTube DL was von Twitch unterladen, ja das funktioniert, das unterstützt
sich sein, ich glaube YouTube DL kann sogar Pornhub mittlerweile, Toss, Monkratoss, Borderlands
ja, Borderlands war ein richtig geiles Game, leider kein gescheites Endgame so wirklich,
übrigens, ich habe mich in dem Video von heute, ich habe mich übelst verlabert, ich
finde den übrigen Thumbnail von heute, ich habe mich übelst verlabert in dem Video,
und zwar hier ganz am Anfang, wo es ums Gehalt geht, da habe ich einfach zwischendrin gesagt,
Alter, ich habe keinen Bock mehr auf die Fragen, ich sage jetzt einfach, was ich verdiene,
und dann habe ich dann einfach gesagt, so ich verdiene das und das im Monat, so jetzt
lässt es mal raus, und dann ist mir im Nachhinein eingefallen, habe ich gedacht, ok, eigentlich
darf ich das, also ich darf das, theoretisch kann man das einem nicht verbieten, aber ich
habe mir gedacht, bevor ich das jetzt mal so im Stream, in so einem Video raushaue, was
potenziell 20.000 plus Leute gucken, ich frage nochmal, ob da, also einfach mal so,
ob da jemand was dagegen hat, wenn ich das sage, ja, das heißt, ich frage mal morgen
oder so meinen Chef, ob da irgendwas aus sein hat, sich dagegen spricht, normalerweise
kann man das nicht untersagen, so wirklich, aber vielleicht gibt es da irgendwas, warum
man meint, das ist keine so gute Idee, und ich frage den mal, und dann mache ich dann,
da brauche ich so ein Clickbait, brauche ich ein Clickbait Video, Gehaltsleak, jetzt ist
es raus, oder irgendwie, ne, ne, ne, das tut es zu langweilig, was brauche ich für Leute,
wir brauchen guten Clickbait Titel, Alter, wie ein Cheko angucken kann, so viel verdiene
ich, ja, das ist eigentlich noch viel besser, das ist schön easy, das ist schön easy, ich
sage einfach, so viel, ich sage, Gehalt, Reveal, so viel, ja, das ist eigentlich ein guter Titel,
bin ich reich, das ist ein guter Cheepbait, das ist ein guter, das mache ich auf Thumbnail,
was mache ich auf Thumbnail, wie reich bin ich, das ist noch besser gestellt, die Frage,
in einem Monat, das ist gut, also, Gehalt, Gehalt, Reveal, so viel verdiene ich in einem
Monat, und auf Thumbnail mache ich den Text, wie reich bin ich, das ist so geiler Clickbait,
Alter, aber, und auf dem Thumbnail muss ich dann, wollte ich gerade sagen, auf dem Thumbnail
verpixel ich dann irgendwie so einen riesen Geldkoffer oder sowas, das ist eine gute
Idee, so war das, perfekt, gibt es wirklich Leute, die SAP mögen, außer SAP Consultants,
was genau macht SAP überhaupt, das frage ich mich bis heute, ehrlich gesagt, kann mir
das jemand erklären, ich weiß es nicht, ich weiß nur, dass es teuer ist und die ganzen
Business Leute das haben und Business Zeugs damit machen, naja, wie gesagt, das funktioniert,
soll ich das zeigen oder glaubst du es mir, ach du Scheiße, ach du große Scheiße, das
ist ja, Excel ist die Idee desjenigen, der nicht programmieren kann, also Excel ist die
Idee der Manager, ach es geht nicht mehr, ach so, ja Moment, das können wir ausprobieren,
ob ich YouTube DL noch machen kann, Sack, Sack, ich probiere es aus, Sack, das ist auch
so eine Scheiß-MMO-Abkürzung, Sack, ne hat nichts mit Security zu tun, sondern mit Sekunde,
so was laden wir jetzt mal runter, hier das da, ja mal gucken, ob das noch funktioniert,
YouTube DL, aber hier, welches komische Verzeichnis, bin ich denn da gelandet, YouTube, ich kann
nicht mehr tippen, YouTube DL, Pause-Camp, oh, ein Gun, YouTube DL updaten, das ist bestimmt
uralt, Windows, please, updaten, YouTube DL updaten, was zum Geier macht das da, what
the fuck, das soll einfach nur, das soll einfach nur YouTube DL updaten und nicht das ganze
Internet, Chat, wer war das von euch, seid ihr schon drin, ach ok, das war anscheinend
alles dafür nötig, dass mein YouTube DL updatet, ok guck mal, das ist über ein Jahr alt mein
YouTube DL gewesen, ok probier mal aus, ob es jetzt funktioniert, sieht gut aus, ja,
schreibs, das funktioniert, aber ich breche jetzt mal ab, oh kann ich da, ojeje, das traue
ich RM nicht zu, das muss ich so löschen, ja ja funktioniert noch, also, warst du also
nie Friseur, jetzt ist es raus Leute, ich war nie der Friseur, jetzt ist es jetzt, es hat
Jahre gedauert, aber jetzt ist es raus, liegt, ABAP Programmierung, sag mal ABAP, jetzt mal
ernsthaft, was ich bisher davon gesehen habe, ist es keinerlei Sprache, wo ich auch nur
im Traum dran denken würde sie zu lernen, weil guckt euch das mal an, wtf, das sieht
aus als hätte man Kobold und Basic miteinander verheiratet, SQL, Kobold und Basic zusammen,
das Thumbnail ist, ja das Thumbnail finde ich auch ganz gut geworden, Supported Sides,
guck mal hier was die da alles drin haben, guck mal was die da alles drin haben, bei
YouTube DL, ist da, ist da, Moment, ja siehste, kannst du grad vorne Videos downloaden mit
YouTube DL, warum das ganze Ding jetzt noch YouTube DL heißt, fragwürdig, aber ich würde
so ein bekanntes Projekt auch nicht umbenennen, 94.000 Sterne, das dürfte eines der größten
und bekanntesten Projekte auf GitHub sein, in was ist denn das eigentlich programmiert,
das ist irgendein Python Ding oder, oder JavaScript, was ist denn das, ja, Python ist das, ja,
ich hab jetzt schon, ich hab jetzt schon ein gutes Clickbait zusammen, ja genau, nicht
nur verpixeln Geldkoffer, sondern irgendwie, ich weiß was ich reinmache, ich weiß was
ich reinmache, so zum Witz für den Stream, weil der Stream das weiß, ich mach einen
verpixelten Opel Agila in grün rein, wenn das verpixeln ist, erkennste eh nicht was
das für ein Auto ist, aber der Stream weiß ja, dass ich so ein Massive Auto hab, okay,
noch mal schnell Chat gucken, jaja so was mach ich, so was mach ich, Goldhaufen oder
irgendwas, mach ne Winralizenz rein, nee der Witz ist mittlerweile abgefahren, das haben
schon so viele Leute gemacht, so was passiert, wenn man eine Winralizenz bestellt, Leute,
könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wisst ihr was passiert, wenn man eine Winralizenz bestellt,
man bekommt eine Winralizenz, das wars, diese Winralizenz Videos sind die unspektakulärsten
aller Zeiten, man bestellt ne Lizenz und man bekommt ne Lizenz, nein, damit hätte ich
ja nie gerechnet, warum so ein altes Auto, weil ich kaum Auto fahr und das noch fährt,
warum soll ich mir ein neues kaufen, warum soll ich mir ein neues kaufen, was ist heute
auf dem Plan, um 22 Uhr schlafen gehen ist auf dem Plan, aha, zum Glück verdient SAP
damit nicht ihr Geld, Quatsch, das kann ich nicht machen, das erkennt, Leute man darf
es mit Clickbait nicht übertreiben, gerade diese Kombination ist total ausgelutscht,
die Leute sind dumm, aber die Leute sind, also die sind dumm und erkennen dumme Muster,
also die Leute erkennen mittlerweile, dass das Clickbait ist, ne, der Unterschied dazwischen
ist, das ist nur lokal für meinen User, das ist systemweit, ja, wie gesagt, das frage
ich mich auch und nein, wir machen kein Ababstream, wie hast du den Friseur kennengelernt, einfach
durch YouTube damals, ihr wohnt ja, nein, nicht durch YouTube, guckt mal, mein erstes Video,
mein erstes Video, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich das überhaupt noch irgendwo hab, das
ist mein erstes Video, genau, das ist mein erstes Video, das hab ich nochmal neu hochgeladen
und im Abspann, den ich rausgeschnitten hab, weil ich dumm bin, ah hier nochmal komplett,
genau, so und der Abspann, der Abspann von meinem allerersten Video, das kann ich euch
übrigens nicht zeigen, den Abspann, weil da ist Musik drinne und zwar im Intro was von
den apokalyptischen Reitern und im Outro irgendwas von den Toten Hosen, das kann, deswegen kann
ich nicht abspielen, so und jetzt pass mal auf, was in meinem ersten Video im Outro drinne
stand, das steht drinne, nächstes Video war wahrscheinlich Dual Kommentar mit meinem Kumpel
dem Friseur, so also wie kann ich den Friseur nicht, der hatte damals, der hatte damals
die ganzen Xbox Accounts, die alles so komisch geplant waren, xxderfriseur, xfriseur, iderfriseur,
der hatte, der hat glaub ich, der hat keine Ahnung, Fabian hat ohne Scheiß 15 Xbox Accounts,
so also ich kenne den aus dem MMO, ich kenne den Friseur nämlich aus Dark Age of Camelot,
bestes MMO aller Zeiten Leute, weißte ich, hat es jemand von euch gespielt, ich gebe
zu Grafik ist Massive, massiver Painz Champ in der heutigen Zeit, was will man so viele
Accounts, das muss man Fabian fragen, keine Ahnung, aber bestes PvP, was es jemals gegeben
hat, in einem MMO Leute, beste, ich würde es heute auf gar keinen Fall mehr spielen,
ich meine es sieht schon scheiße aus, man muss mal ehrlich sehen, aber das ist schon
richtig nice, man darf nicht vergessen, das sind keine NPCs, das sind alles Spieler hier
auf dem Bild, alles Spieler, wurde mal gut aufgepilzt hier, ahja Camelot an Chained kommt
wahrscheinlich nie raus in dem Tempo, wie die da weitermachen, aber ohne Scheiß Leute,
bestes MMO aller Zeiten, jetzt zu spielen lohnt sich nicht mehr, jemand guckt euch
das mal an, wie das ausschaut, und das checkt auch niemand mehr heute, der da neu mit anfängt,
aber ansonsten ist das massiv geil, hast du das gespielt während dem Arbeitsamtkurs,
also ich hab das gespielt von 2000, Moment, das kam 2011, 2001 oder so raus, ich hab das
gespielt von Release, sogar ein paar Tage vorher, von Release bis 2010, habe ich das wirklich
täglich gespielt, oder 2010 stimmt nicht, nein das stimmt nicht Leute, ich hab aufgehört
bevor ich Youtube angefangen habe, 2009, also ich hab das gespielt von 2001 bis 2009 quasi
täglich, mehrere Stunden, wobei ich die letzten zwei, drei Jahre nur noch FVR gespielt hab
mit meinen acht Leuten da, abends zwei, drei Stunden, so und dann hab ich ein paar mal
immer wieder reingeguckt in das Game, ich hab da tausende Stunden drinne, ey ich hab
da bestimmt, frag mich nicht, 12.000 Spielstunden über alle Scheiße oder so, wie viele Stunden
hatten ja, how much hours one year, ok 8.760, ja das kommt hin, ist gar kein Problem, 12.000
Stunden, easy, easy, 12.000 Stunden, ich hab das 10 Jahre gespielt, wenn ich das 10 Jahre
gespielt hab, hab ich doch mal locker eineinhalb Jahre, aber mal locker eineinhalb Jahre in
Zeitsatz gespielt, locker, locker, bestes, bestes MMO, ja und daher kenne ich den Fabian,
wir haben auf dem gleichen Server damals gespielt und der Fabian hat damals schon das gemacht
was er heute immer noch gerne macht, rerollen, das war einer der ersten 50er, das war max
level damals hier in dem Game, auf dem Server oder ich weiß gar nicht ob er 50 geworden
ist, zumindest eines der am höchsten gelevelten Leute zur damaligen Zeit mit der jeweiligen
Klasse, der hat nämlich eine übelste Kackklasse gespielt, zumindest für Gruppen ja und irgendwann
hat er einfach rerollt auf alle Charaktere, damals musste man Leute, damals musste man
noch alle Charaktere löschen, dass man rerollen konnte auf einem anderen Realm, alle Charaktere
gelöscht, rerollt, dann hat er aufgelevelt, 2 Monate später hat er wieder rerollt, der
Fabian war wirklich, der war nur am rerollen, das war im Prinzip wie heute immer noch bei
den ingl. Games spielt, ja daher kenne ich den und den Mastercrapper, den Mastercrapper
kenne ich auch, also eigentlich kenne ich den Mastercrapper und über den Mastercrapper
kenne ich den Fabian, so rum. MMO Freundschaften, da sieht man, da sieht man mal wieder Real
Life RL Stells ist komplett overrated, ich habe Corona Quarantäne gelebt zu Zeiten wo
es noch kein Corona gab, ja. So, ja ja also man kann übelst viel Geld in Autos reinhauen,
wenn man will, ich habe auf der Arbeit auch so einen, der ist permanent am Autotunen,
was witzig ist, also der hat übelst, der hat eben, ich glaube irgendeinen BMW hat er,
übelst am Autotunen und auch laufen sich irgendwelche komischen Abgase, Abgasrohre und
haste nicht gesehen bestellt und einmal wollte er sich bei AliExpress irgendwelche Teile
bestellen, hat dann festgestellt, ah nee das wird aber zu heiß und dann vertraut er
dem Chinesen Kram nicht, dass wenn es so heiß wird, dass es da nicht schmilzt oder so und
irgendwann ist dann seine Freundin schwanger geworden, da meinte er so ein halbes Jahr
später, ey man, es war eine scheiß Idee mit dem Auto, hättest du es mal gewusst, hättest
du es nicht gemacht, hättest du mir ein anderes Auto gekauft, nicht getutet, jetzt braucht
er die Kohle und das Auto will natürlich so keiner haben, Pech gehabt, tja, aber ich
mein vielleicht, vielleicht hätte er die Freundin nicht gekriegt ohne das Auto, man weiß es
ja nie, ja, du hast ein vollverschlüsseltes Arch, gut Job, Leute, ich hab echt ein Problem,
ist ernsthaft, ich komm mit meinen, also ich komm nicht mit den Leuten klar, die in meinem
Alter sind, also so, so auf persönlicher, persönlicher Ebene komm ich mit 99% der Leute
in meinem Alter nicht klar, ist einfach so, also klar schon mit Leuten, die ähnlich denken
wie ich und auch irgendwie Gaming-Gedöns machen und da im Internet sich auskennen und
sonst wie, aber ohne scheiß 99% der 36 oder 35 plus Jährigen, mit denen komm ich nicht
klar, das sind so ganz komische Leute, das sind Leute, die gehen irgendwie noch auf Facebook
und posten irgendwelche komischen Bildchen und lachen sich da drüber kaputt und so,
so Dinge, die seit 10 Jahren outdated sind, ja, das sind Leute, die denken, keine Ahnung,
Pepe wäre was für Nazis oder so, die checken gar nichts, was im Internet abgeht, ja, Facebook,
ja, richtig Pains-Champ, ich mein hier im Chat nicht, im Chat die Leute hier, weiß ich,
die wären sonst ja nicht da, ja ich komm auch mit, das stimmt schon, ich komm auch
mit 99% der anderen Leuten nicht klar, alter Mädchen 2 hör mal auf, sowas kommt als nächstes,
Everquest, gibt's da wohl Leute, die noch extrem reincripen, ja, aber das Spiel ist eigentlich
mehr oder weniger dead, wenn du Dark dir ein bisschen angucken willst, dann spiel auf dem
Free-Shart, der hat noch ganz gute Spielerzahlen, kannst auch ESO spielen, wenn du zumindest
ein Spiel haben willst, was von manchen der Dark-Beteiligten mitentwickelt wurde, aber
ESO hat mit Dark an sich gar nichts zu tun, ein bisschen das PvP vielleicht, aber ansonsten
eigentlich, guck, der hat ganz gute Spielzahlen, ich mein mehr als wenn es, ne, für das ohne
Scheiß, für das, dass das ein Free-Shart ist, für das, dass das ein Free-Shart ist,
ist das nicht schlecht am Wochenende 2000 Spieler hier am Start, ne, man muss hier die ganzen
Reiche zusammenrechnen, oh ist schon in Ordnung, ja ich hab halt hier auch auf dem Free-Shart
gespielt, hier so bis, bis keine Ahnung, hier so irgendwie Mitte, Mitte, Ende letzten
Jahres irgendwie so und ich hab ja auch schon wieder nen übelst High-Rank-Solo-Char und
bin voll reingesuchtet ein paar Monate, doch, doch hab ich auch, aber ich muss dir ehrlich
sagen, ich bin mit World of Warcraft nie warm geworden, das lag aber da dran, weil entgegen
Internetmeinung hat World of Warcraft MMOs nicht erfunden, das ist ja so ein bisschen
ein Running-Gag, viele Leute schreiben das mittlerweile so aus Spaß rein, obwohl sie
eigentlich wissen, dass es nicht so ist, weil in der Zeit lang die Leute das wirklich dachten,
wo gleich first MMO und sowas in der Richtung, World of Warcraft, ihr werdet lachen, World
of Warcraft galte damals, unter den damals quasi schon hart eingesottenen MMO-Spielern
als Kinder-MMO, als weichgespültes Kinder-MMO, ich mein, damit hatten sie nicht unrecht,
wenn man sich guckt, was da für komische Gestalten teilweise rumgerannt sind, heute
ist World of Warcraft für viele so das nostalgische beste Game ever, das Snoop-MMO, was gar nicht
stimmt, ne, geradezu zu Classic schonmal, schonmal gar nicht, weil das, das war sicherlich
nicht schwer, gerade im Vergleich zu heut irgendwelchen High-End-Rate-Geschichten, aber
das Knowledge hat ihr damals halt komplett gefehlt, doch, doch, ich hab auch ein bisschen
World of Warcraft gespielt, aber nie, der großartig gesuchtet wie Dark, Quick-Maths-Big-Prain
hier im Kopf, wie kommt es wieder, tja, das ist ne gute Frage, wie kommt es, dass ich
wieder so viele Videos mache, Leute, jetzt, ich hab ne Frage, der Chat weiß ja sowas manchmal
besser als ich, wisst ihr, warum das so ist, ich weiß es nicht, warum mach ich ausgerechnet
jetzt wieder Videos und hab die letzten sechs Jahre keine gemacht, na, Stonks kanns nicht
sein, für Stonks hätt ich die letzten sechs Jahre überhaupt Videos machen können, weil's
Bock macht, ja, das ist richtig, aber warum jetzt auf einmal wieder, ich glaube, ich weiß
warum, Leute, ich weiß warum, Moment, ich kanns euch zeigen, warum ich wieder Videos
mach, ähm, und zwar, ich hab ja irgendwann mal im Dezember, genau, ich hab irgendwann
im Dezember mal das Video zu Black Friday gemacht, dann hab ich wieder ein paar Wochen
nix gemacht, hab ich mir gedacht, ey, weißt was, ich mach noch ein Weihnachtsgeschenke-Video
und dann gab's Battlefield 3 für umsonst auf Steam oder Origin, irgendwo, gab's das
umsonst, so, und dann hab ich mir gedacht, alter, nimmst jetzt einfach ein paar Battlefield-Videos
auf, hab ich ja dann hier auch gemacht und gleichermaßen hatte ich die Idee, warum mach
ich nicht einfach mal ein paar IT-Technik-Videos und dann hab ich dann damit angefangen, hab
ich mir gedacht, das ist eigentlich ganz cool, weil ich hatte ja auch so ein bisschen das
Problem, ich konnte nicht so wirklich gamingbezogenen Content machen, weil, was willst du machen,
großartig, wenn es grad kein Game gibt, wo du Bock drauf hast.
Ne, mit Corona hat das gar nix zu tun. Corona hat das gar nix zu tun. Das ist ne gute Frage.
Würdest du zurückblickend sagen, dass die Zeit verschwendet war, also du meinst die
Zeit, diese 12.000 Stunden oder was auch immer, wo ich da auch gespielt hab? Nö, warum?
Ich würde mir sogar eher wünschen, ich könnte noch weiterspielen, aber das Game ist halt
dead. Ich würde mich freuen, wenn ich heute noch Kreisel-Grind machen könnte. Da hab
ich übrigens auch mal ein Video zugemacht in letzter Zeit. Nö, überhaupt nicht. Gar
nicht. Ich würd mir sogar umgedreht eher wünschen, dass es wieder ein Game gibt, wo
ich 12.000 Stunden grinden will. Der Archlinux-Nerd ist am Start. Danke schön für den Prime
Sub. Ja, das ist wichtig. Das ist unglaublich wichtig. Das muss man immer mitteilen den
Leuten. Ich benutze übrigens auch Archlinux. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dir schon mal erzählen
hab. Wobei, geht man Jaro als Archlinux durch? Ich mein, das ist ein Archlinux, hat aber
so ein paar Zwischenrepos. Das ist nicht pures Arch, oder? Man muss leiden bei der Installation.
Ja, Stripes, dann kann man das jetzt nicht gehen. Das ist eine geile Idee. Das ist eine
geile Idee für mein MMO-Video. Ich war jahrelang ein Lockdown-Prepper. Ich muss noch besser
in solche Clickbait-Titel-Generation im Kopf reinkommen. Ja, du vielleicht nicht. Das
kann man wahrscheinlich so pauschal nicht sagen. Es gibt bestimmt genug Leute, die
haben da kein Problem damit. Und warum? Ich meine, da magst du wenigstens eine Sache
an dir, dein Auto. Also ich mein, ich bezieh's jetzt nicht explizit auf dich, sondern klar,
seit letztem Tag hat sich auch wieder übelst einer geflamed gefühlt im Chat, weil ich
gesagt hab, dich, obwohl ich gar nicht dich gemeint hab, den das geschrieben hat.
Ja, das kommt auch dazu. Also ich komm auch mit 99% der Leute nicht klar. Ja, ist echt
so. Also die Sache ist halt ernsthaft so. Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass ich bald
40, also bald, bald ist übertrieben, ich werd 37 dieses Jahr, dass ich bald 40 werde. Man
muss sich das mal vorstellen. Ich werd 40. Ab da geht's los, dass Frauen in die Wechseljahre
kommen, ey. Mit 40, so ungefähr. Da geht's langsam los. Langsam. Ich sag jetzt nicht
instance vorbei. Muss ich mal vorstellen, ich bin schon in so einem Alter. Das kann
man sich gar nicht vorstellen. Zum Glück bekommen Männer sowas nicht. Du musst mal
Kinder zeugen. Ja, ich weiß, ey. Wenn ich Kinder will, da muss jetzt, da muss jetzt
ran. Ja, hast du recht. Aber ich will gar keine Kinder. Ich glaub, das ist alles der
schlimmsten Sachen, die ich mir gerade vorstellen könne, Kinder zu kriegen. Dann ist vorbei.
Mit Daily Stream. Dann ist Schluss. Also außerdem, da hängt irgendwas an meiner Decke. Ah,
das ist ein Fussel. Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was da an meiner Decke hängt. MonkaS, MonkaS.
Nee, das ist wirklich nur ein Fussel. Das ist wirklich nur ein Fussel. Ähm, das wollte
ich jetzt gerade sagen. Ja, dann ist vorbei, wenn ich Kinder krieg mit Daily Stream. Mal
davon abgesehen. Um Kinder zu kriegen fehlt mir ja auch ein ganz entscheidendes, äh,
was man da, was man da noch dazu braucht, ja. Also, insofern ist das eh keine Option
aktuell. Geld, das auch. Geld, Geld hast du nie genug. Ja, ich mein, ohne Frau wird da
schwierig, ja. Ich mein, in der heutigen Zeit, ja, ne, gibt's ja nichts, was nix gibt, aber
das funktioniert noch nicht so. Da stimmt, gleichaltrige Menschen sind ganz merkwürdig.
Ich hab paar Softwareprojekte für die Arbeit tatsächlich nach meinem neuen Benamungsschema
benannt. Beispielsweise hab ich letztens, ähm, einen, ähm, was gebastelt, was ich
mit zwei Fakta-Authentifizierung anmelden kann. Das ist der Orth-Champ. Und, äh, wir hatten
auch schon den Proxy-Champ und den Performance-Champ hatten wir auch schon. Ja, ganz wichtig.
Also, falls, falls sich mal jemand irgendwie irgendwo neu anfängt und loggt sich auf
dem Linux-Surfer ein und ihr seht dann, dass irgendwo im Root-Verzeichnis irgendwas mit
Champ rumliegt, dann habt ihr wahrscheinlich Überbleibseln von mir gefunden. Gibt bestimmt
oder garantiert. Äh, selten. Ah, richtig Hardcore-Arch. By the way, User. Es ist vorbei,
das werden wir nicht mehr sehen. Glaubst du, wird es in nächstem Jahr noch neue Battlefield-Games
geben? Ja, glaub ich. Also, es sagen ja viele, wenn das neue Battlefield-Game nicht gut,
also nicht gut ankommt, dann ist die Reihe tot. Leute, es ist nix tot, was nicht bis
zum letzten möglichen Cent gemolken ist. Guckt euch mal an, was EA beispielsweise gemacht
hat mit Medal of Honor. Das war schon nicht gut, das Reboot und danach kommt noch ein
zweites, es war auch nicht gut. Und dann kommen noch irgendwelche Mobile-Games im Zweifelsfall
vorn. Oder guckt euch mal Dungeon-Keeper an. Kennt jemand von euch noch Dungeon-Keeper?
Eines der besten Spiele aller Zeiten. Das hat EA auch komplett zerstört mit irgendeinem
komischen Mobile-Game zum Schluss. Für die Zoomer unter uns, die das nicht mehr kennen,
Leute. Dungeon-Keeper. Eines der besten Games überhaupt. Das ist Dungeon-Keeper 2. Dungeon-Keeper,
ja. So, und da gab es in irgendwann Jahrzehnte später so ein Mobile-Game vorn und es war
einfach schlecht. Einfach nur schlecht. Und man musste irgendwie drei Tage warten, bis
man einen neuen Block abbauen kann und sowas. Einfach nur schlecht. Und dann war es tot.
Also, selbst wenn Battlefield floppt, das nächste, wird es weitere Battlefield-Games
geben. 100 Pro. In irgendeiner Art und Weise wird es das geben. Ähm. Früher hab ich immer
gelabert. Und fand mich dann übelst geil, dass ich 20 Minuten zu einem Thema labern kann,
aber mittlerweile mach ich so, ich schreib mir ein paar Punkte auf, weil ich, weil ich
hab mir selbst ja die ein oder anderen alten Videos angeguckt und hab einfach festgestellt,
vom Inhalt her ist das schon okay, aber das ist einfach viel zu lang. Also viel zu, viel
zu viel zwischendurch. So, und jetzt hab ich ein paar Punkte. Manchmal auch ein paar Punkte
geben, ja. So. Äh, ich muss dir ehrlich sagen, ich hab noch nie nen Gentoo installiert. Das
einzige Mal, wo ich Gentoo wirklich live im Einsatz gesehen hab, ist bei uns einem auf
der Arbeit, der hat ein neues Notebook bekommen, ne. Kein Notebook, stimmt nicht. Ne VM. Ne
VM und, äh, oder doch ein Notebook, ich weiß es nicht aus dem Prinzip, egal, und wollte
sich darauf nen Gentoo installieren und hat drei Tage gebraucht, weil das zigmal neu kompilieren
musste, dass der Colonel seinen Netzwerkkartentreiber überhaupt enthält. Also, ich glaube, das
will ich nicht machen. Ja, dann ist kein Wunder, dass es nicht geht. Warum denn eigentlich
nicht? Ich mein, du kannst User-Repos verwenden. Ich mein, es ist halt ein bisschen einfacher
für Kacknoobs, ne, aber, na gut, das ist klar, die echten Hardcore-Artschleute wollen
das natürlich nicht. Wie? Man kann Artschleute halbwegs komfortabel installieren? Wird das
jetzt auch zum Nuke-Betriebssystem? Only Suckless-Software, ja, ich verwende auch nur Suckless-Software,
wobei ich sagen muss, ich hab mal ne Zeit lang das Suckless-Terminal verwendet. Suckless-Terminal,
ich verwende heute noch den Suckless-Screen-Log. Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, wovon ich spreche,
wissen wahrscheinlich null, was ich meine. Suckless ist irgendeine Entwicklergruppe,
die komische Open-Source-Software für Linux macht, die im Prinzip nichts kann, aber schön
in C programmiert ist. Was macht dein 3D-Drucker? Der ist gerade aus und steht rum. Was will
er denn auch machen? Ja, der Artschleutung-Speedrun, wir haben letztens in den Artsch-Install-Speedrun
geguckt, der war glaub ich in 1,5 Minuten durch oder so. Kann Mikrotik, ja, können sie. Die
können angeblich sogar mittlerweile mit, entweder ist es schon in der offiziellen Firmware oder
mit irgendeinem Beta-Package, können die sogar angeblich WireGuard mittlerweile. Da bin ich
nicht agil genug für. Ich glaube, ich glaube, er ist, wann ist er geboren? 1988, 1985? Irgendwie,
wir sind ungefähr ins, ich glaube, ich bin einen Ticken älter. Aber dass ich sehr wie
Monte bin, würde ich jetzt mal nicht so unterschreiben. Keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht. Ich meine,
ich kenne ihn nicht wirklich gut, aber ich würde sagen, eher nicht. Die biologische
Uhr läuft ab, ja. Das könnte man natürlich machen, wenn ich es mir mit 90 dort noch mal
anders überlege. Was machst du heute? Ich gehe in einer halben Stunde schlafen. Ja,
dass sie schneller müde sind, das kann, das kenne ich, das kenne ich. Das kenne ich.
Das kenne ich, das kenne ich.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, der Zug ist abgefahren. Twitch soll günstiger werden. Echt? Globale
Community durch lokale Preise für Abonnements aufbauen. Was soll denn lokale Preise sein?
Alter, Wall of Text. Meine Güte, ey, mehr Text. Alter, steht da auch irgendwas? Ach,
erste Länder, Mexiko und die Türkei. Was interessiert mich denn, was die Türken und
die Mexikaner machen? Sobald sich das machen kann, mache ich das auch günstiger. Sobald
es bei mir das günstiger möglich ist, mache ich das günstiger. Wisst ihr, was noch geiler
wäre? Es wird günstiger, aber man müsste Twitch nicht mehr so viel von abgeben. Ja,
nach Indien oder so wahrscheinlich. Wobei, Indien ist ja Out zum Outsourcen. Hab ich
so den Eindruck. Nee. Geh ich nicht drauf, wer weiß, was da dahinter ist. Guck mal, wenn
schon mal eine Vorschau nicht lädt, das heißt irgendwas. So sieht es aus, das habe ich tatsächlich
schon mal gemacht. Ich habe tatsächlich schon mal was kommodiert mit Gagway in einem Komet.
Das gibt es garantiert noch. Aber es gibt viel weniger solcher Games. Könnt ihr euch
noch dran erinnern, noch vor gar nicht allzu vielen Jahren gab es total viele G-Bait Links,
so nach dem Motto, boah, guck dir mal das hier an. Und dann hast du dann draufgeklickt
und dann kam es noch auf so einer Seite raus, haha, sie wurden erwischt, ihnen wurden 270
Credits abgenommen, registrieren sie sich jetzt auch hier. So diese G-Bait Games, wo
es darum ging, die Leute mit einem Link rein zu G-Baiten, gibt es gar nicht mehr. Gibt
es gar nicht so wirklich mehr. Du meinst du das Remake von Alarmstufe Rot, das war tatsächlich
gut, ja? Alarmstufe Rot war aber auch so ein Kindheitsgame bei mir. Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass es ein Generals Remake gibt. Es gibt ein Generals Remake, wirklich? Ah, das ist
ein Mod. Aha, wusste ich gar nicht. Ja, das Portal Mod, da habe ich ja nicht gespielt.
Wusste ich gar nicht, dass es da ein Mod zu gibt, das ist cool. Stellt euch vor, Battlefield
6 Free to Play. Also wie gesagt, ich glaube nicht, dass es Free to Play wird. Eventuell
so eine Mini Basic Version am Wochenende oder so, keine Ahnung, aber das Battle Royale,
und das ist so sicher wie das Armen in der Kirche, ich weiß nicht warum Leute überhaupt
noch vermuten, das könnte ein Battle Royale, das ist sicher, das Battle Royale wird es
geben. 100%. Die sehen was Warzone für eine Kohle macht, die sehen es selbst, die sehen
auch selbst was Apex für eine Kohle macht. Und Apex und so ein modernes Military Setting,
ich würde sagen, die haben nicht so viele Schnittmenge, oder die, die sich überschneiden
sind wahrscheinlich überschaubar, und das spricht einfach noch mal zusätzliche, eine Riesenanzahl
zusätzlicher Leute an. Und dann haben die Apex und Battlefield Battle Royale, ist doch
kein Unterschied. Also das glaubt nicht, dass das denen sonderlich viel Selbstkonkurrenz
macht, aber das ist sicher, das wird es geben, 100%. Ja gut, du kannst ja erstmal zwei Tage
warten. Es braucht auf jeden Fall viel RAM und Festplattenplatz. Ne, weiß ich nicht,
ich hab auch noch nichts von EA gehört, ich hab euch ja gestern erzählt, dass ich ne Einladung
gekriegt hab, oder ne Einladung bekomme, eventuell, wenn ich zustimme, dass ich nichts sage, was
die mir dann mitteilen werden. Öffentlich bis zum so und so finden. Ich hab auch nix
bekommen, also mal gucken, mal gucken, was da so kommt. Also es könnte sein, dass die
für die, also was ich vermute ist, was ich vermute ist, und ich hab ja noch nichts bekommen
von denen, deswegen kann ich jetzt einfach mal vermuten, ich vermute mal die wollen wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen Gameplay oder Zeug auch sammeln für ihren Reveal Stream. Und vielleicht haben
wir Glück, und wir sehen mein Name im Reveal Stream dann irgendwann im Killfeed aufploppen
oder so, wenn sie zwei Minuten Multiplayer zeigen. Also, mein Ingame Name. Info Holden.
Sebaro weiß es. Ne, ich glaube so heiße ich nur Bad Company 2. Nicht Info Holden. Doch
ohne Scheiß, das mach ich. Wenn ich wirklich zu dem Event eingeladen werde, nenne ich mein
Gamertag Info Holden. Das ist so richtig dumm. Vor allem die Amis checken doch eh nicht,
was das heißen soll. Das ist so richtig dämlich. Aber natürlich auch für LeadSpeak, dass man
es nicht so offensichtlich sieht. Cute Chat, das ist noch besser, ich nenne mich Cute Chat.
Excellent. Vorhold Senpai. Na, das ist mir dann schon zu viel Reaps in. Kann meine Hochschule
eigentlich sehen, was ich so im Internet reibe, wenn ich vergesse aus OpenVPN zu gehen? Ja
klar oder? Nö, wahrscheinlich nicht. Ist auch eine dumme Frage. Also höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht, weil die meisten Seiten mittlerweile über SSL gehen. Und Seiten, die über SSL,
also HTTPS, TLS ist es ja eigentlich, wenn man korrekt sein will, gehen, sehen die auch
nichts. Für alles Unverschlüsselte ja, das könnte man sehen, wenn man da irgendwie mitschneidet
unterwegs, aber naja, was einer macht, denke ich eher nicht, aber man weiß ja nie. Lokale
Preise, bald gibt es Subs aus Indien. Moment, das heißt, ich kann dann in Indien Subscriben,
ja das ist nice. Dann wird es für die Schweizer teurer. Stimmt. Aber vielleicht wird es ja
bei 5 Dollar. Sag mal, das ist doch jetzt schon teurer oder? Wir bezahlen 5 Euro oder 5 Dollar?
Ist es nicht jetzt schon so? Oder wird das immer in? Ne, das kann ja nicht sein. Moment,
warum kostet das 5,99 Schweizer Franken? Ne, oder? Das wäre ja noch mehr, das wäre
noch jebaiteter. 479, Alter. Tja, Chat, das frage ich mich auch. Rico hat einen guten
Punkt angesprochen. Wie schaffe ich es eigentlich, so wenige Subs zu haben? Wie geht das überhaupt?
Vielleicht ist der Cute Chat doch nicht so cute. Sonst würden jetzt alle Subs, die
noch nicht gesubbt haben, mit ihrem Prime-Sub, den sie den Monat noch frei haben. Wir sind
wenige dafür Massive IQ, das ist richtig. Das funktioniert, das Sub-Jebait funktioniert
immer. Domboy, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub. Jetzt überlegt euch mal, hätte ich noch mehr
Subs und jeder Sub wird euren IQ steigern, dann würde euer Kopf so aussehen mittlerweile.
Das passt ja gar nicht mehr rein. Das muss langsam dosiert werden. Moment, die Copy-Pasta
geht länger. Die kenne ich noch länger. Die gibt es in noch einer längeren Variante.
Aber die kriege ich aus dem Kopf nicht mehr hin. Laurin2698, Dankeschön, 2 Monate Prime-Subscription.
Oh jetzt kommt die Massive Copy-Pasta hier. Jetzt, jetzt. Never sub, never donated, Adblock,
on stolen Laptop. Endlich muss ich euch das mal zeigen. Markieren wo wir waren. Ja, jetzt
haben wir es. Never subbed, never donated, Adblock, on stolen Laptop, neighbors, Wi-Fi,
mamas Haus, stolen solar panels, stolen suns, ne das ist nicht den, den ich kenne. Das ist
nicht den, den ich kenne. Es gab noch irgendeinen besseren. Mein Lieblings Copy-Pasta ist aber,
wo ist die Musik? Mein Lieblings Copy-Pasta war aber immer noch zu Overwatch Zeiten. Ich
weiß gar nicht mehr wie das genau ging, wo man die Leute gebaitet hat mit ihrem Skill-Rating.
Also sprich, ich hab dann immer in die Chats gepostet, random in irgendwelche Streams gegangen
und hab dann sowas geschrieben wie bitte schreibt nicht im Chat wenn ihr nicht mindestens 2000,
wenn ihr nicht mindestens Highskill seid, 2000 SR plus, 2000 SR plus ist halt nichts gewesen
in Overwatch. Das hat jeder gehabt, der das Spiel zum ersten Mal gespielt hat. Dann haben
sich die Leute immer richtig krass tschüben lassen, nur nach dem Motto, LOL, High, High
SR, 2000 plus, LOL, K Knoob. Das war so geil, die haben sich teilweise am Anfang, haben
die sich mega triggern lassen mit so sinnloser Copy-Pasta. Das hab ich immer gerne gespammt.
Man darf nicht vergessen, ich war damals auch schon 33. Ne 2016, ja doch, kommt hin. Da
hat der 33 jährige da gesitzt, gesessen daheim und hat einen Switch Copy-Pasta gemacht.
Ich hab mich gefreut, wenn die Leute darauf angesprungen sind. Ja. Ich glaub's nicht ernsthaft
euch das da anklicken jetzt, oder? Lösch die, wir können höchstens die Nachricht löschen.
Das find ich gemein, sowas. Vor allem im Hinblick dessen, dass er wahrscheinlich keine Ahnung
hat. Rionic on fire, ach ne, Rionic fire, soviel drei Monate, dankeschön für den Sub.
Massive Subscription hier. Keine exe Download Links hier. Ja gut, dann ist die Verbindung
über SSL nicht safe. Tja. Oh komm mal, 200 IQ Sub Emote, das ist,
das ist auch Big Brain. Ja gut, dazu musste aber erst einmal ein Rechner
dran kommen. Tja, das kommt drauf an, wie lange es diesen ganzen Kram noch gibt. Wahrscheinlich
ist es gar nicht so doof, weil ich davon ausgehe, dass gerade dieses ganze Cobalt Zeug und sogar
ein bisschen die Cloud verfolgen wird. Wie sinnvoll das ist, Host selbst zu lernen,
beziehungsweise mein Mainframe selbst zu lernen, hab ich so meine Bedenken, weil IBM versucht
ja auch, dass man den Kram bei ihnen in der Cloud laufen lassen kann. Also eigene Mainframe
Hardware eher weniger, aber Cobalt und sowas, ja, ohne Scheiß, ich glaube, das lohnt sich
immer noch. Aber natürlich nicht als einziges, ne. Also ich würde mich nicht darauf verlassen,
dass ich jetzt einen krassen Cobalt Shop in den ersten paar Wochen finde, nachdem ich
da das Cobalt Tutorial gemacht hab. Aber wenn man ein bisschen Cobalt Ahnung hat, ist es
glaube ich nicht verkehrt. Es ist aber eklig, ich hab's ja selbst im Stream schon mal ausprobiert.
In die Cloud verfolgt, ey, ist doch echt so. Es gibt ja mittlerweile schon Cobalt zu Java,
Transpiler. Die wandeln dann alten Cobalt Code um in Java. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was
davon besser ist. Dann hat man hässliches Cobalt Transpiled zu Java. Ob das jetzt so
viel geiler ist, ich weiß ja nicht. Chat, das könnt ihr nicht, ne, das kannst du nur,
wenn du zu viele Channel Points hast. Kann ich das anklicken? Moment, ich muss das gerade
mal checken in meiner Vorschau hier. Okay, Thumbnail Concept, zeig mal her. Ne, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das kann ich nicht machen. Man kann es ja verdammt gesehen,
die Leute fallen nicht mehr drauf rein auf so extreme Sachen. Heute muss besser Clickbaited
werden. Die Leute erkennen Muster in sowas und die wissen genau, das ist ein typisches
Gebate, Clickbait. Ja, die Leute sind doof, aber die Leute erkennen dofe Muster. Das ist
was, das hättest du vor zwei Jahren machen können. Meinst du das mit der Mikrowelle?
Das wurde mir auch vorhin empfohlen, ich hab's nicht geguckt. Ich bin begeistert, Leute,
guck mal, wir haben es jetzt ernsthaft geschafft, über ne Stunde nichts anderes zu machen als
zehn Fragen im Chat zu beantworten und drei, vier Sachen zu zeigen. Fertig, easy Content.
Warum mach ich mir überhaupt noch Gedanken darüber, was ich im Stream zeigen könnte?
Die Leute erkennen den Clickbait am Ende, drücken sie trotzdem drauf. Ich glaube, das
überschätzt du, wie dumm dumme Leute sind. Also, die erkennen das schon. Hey, ich teste
da nix. Wer das Video von heute nicht geguckt hat, guckt mal rein, ihr könnt das Video,
weil manche schreiben, ihr guckt gerne Videos zum Einschlafen. Ihr könnt das Video zum
Einschlafen gucken, da gibt's keinen Gameplay dabei. Übrigens, was mich gewundert hat
in den letzten Videos, es haben ein paar Leute was geschrieben von so sinngemäß, also in
dem Video, ich kann es euch einfach zeigen. Hier, genau, das haben tatsächlich einige
geschrieben in dem Video und auch unter den letzten Videos, so nach dem Motto, ob es mich
interessieren würde, für wen ich arbeite und ob ich Probleme damit habe, so wie wohltätig
oder so mein Arbeitgeber ist und das muss ich mal ganz ehrlich, das habe ich ja auch
drunter gar nicht geantwortet, aber ganz ehrlich, es ist mir zu 99% scheißegal, solang es nicht
irgendwas ist mit Tierversuchen oder so oder mit, selbst wenn es ein Waffenhersteller ist,
das würde ich mir vielleicht zweimal überlegen, aber wenn es viel Geld ist, ich meine, ich
muss ja niemand erschießen dafür. Nee, aber, sag mal so Tierversuche und Waffenhersteller
wären vielleicht so Sachen, da würde ich sagen, nee, also Tierversuche würde ich auf
gar keinen Fall machen. Menschenversuche sind okay, ja, da habe ich kein Problem mit, aber
Tierversuche würde ich nicht supporten. Das, da würde ich mir das überlegen, aber ansonsten
ist mir das vollkommen egal, was die da irgendwie machen und es hat auch letztens unter dem
Video, unter dem da vor einer geschrieben, ich glaube noch in dem Battlefield-Video,
da wollte ich, ich habe mir schon fast überlegt, ob ich da mal ein eigenes Video zu machen
sollte, weil ich das interessantes Comment fand, wo ich nämlich glaube, dass in der
Hersteller vollkommen jebaited hat. Wenn ich es finde. Tja, nee, keine Ahnung.
Da hat jemand geschrieben, er wird sich auf jeden Fall das nächste Battlefield kaufen,
weil DICE öffentlich Black Lives Matter unterstützt und gerade deswegen ist das für ihn ein
Pflichtkauf und ich habe mir gedacht, ich müsste zu diesem Comment eigentlich mal ein
eigenes Video machen, nämlich gar nicht so sehr über irgendwelche Charity-Bewegungen
oder dass man Black Lives Matter supportet, das ist glaube ich nur sekundär, sondern
dass der Hersteller damit genau das erreicht, was die erreichen wollen, weil im Kern scheißen
die Hersteller auf alles, was irgendwie Ethik oder irgendwas, das ist den Herstellern vollkommen
egal, aber der Hersteller hat damit genau das geschafft, was er schaffen wollte, der
hat sich quasi so ein schönes Image verpasst, dass sogar die Leute sagen, hey, wir unterstützen
den Hersteller jetzt, also die haben quasi Sellout gemacht, die haben sich quasi so ein
gutes Image damit verpasst, dass die quasi allein schon damit wieder Geld verdienen,
die haben genau das erreicht, was sie wollen, weil ansonsten ist das denen vollkommen egal,
egal in welche Richtung das geht, denen gehts ums Geld, denen gehts eigentlich nur ums Geld,
wie gesagt, Ausnahmen bestätigen die Regeln, das ist das gleiche, das ist das gleiche,
wie wenn du Leute hast, das habe ich auch unter dem letzten Video geschrieben, das ist
das gleiche, wie wenn du Ölkonzerne hast, wenn du Ölkonzerne hast und die jetzt voll
grün sind auf einmal, das ist denen doch auch scheißegal, die wissen einfach nur, dass
es gut ankommt, das ist denen vollkommen egal und Blizzard, Blizzard waren ja eh noch die
geilsten, ne, Blizzard waren eh die geilsten, so nach dem Motto, Hongkong, was, wie, null,
nee nee, Hongkong scheißen wir drauf, interessiert uns überhaupt nicht, äh, Mist, wir haben
zu viele Tencent-Anteile, ach nee, wie, da waren Caster im Bild, ja die schmeißen wir
gleich mit raus, Blizzard voll geschissen auf Hongkong, vollkommen egal, ne, und dann
drei Wochen später, so nach dem Motto, oh ja, wir stehen voll an der Seite von Black
Lives Matter, es geht in dem Fall überhaupt nicht drum, ob man diese Initiativen gut oder
schlecht findet, das ist einfach so, wie nennt man das, so heuschlerig alles, das kannst
du nicht glauben, das kannst du einfach nicht glauben alles, es geht ihm einfach nur um
das eigene Wohl und das ist das, was man erstmal realisieren muss bei der ganzen Geschichte,
es geht dem nur darum, in irgendeiner Art und Weise daraus Kapital zu schlagen, sonst
nix, was das Unternehmen gendert, oder das können die meinetwegen machen, das ist mir,
das ist auch so ein Thema, das geht mir sonst wo vorbei, solang nicht einer von mir erwartet,
dass ich jetzt irgendwelche komischen Zungenbrecher verwende, ich frag mich übrigens bis heute
noch, wie die gendergerechte Variante von Bankkaufmann ist, oder von System, IT Systemkaufmann,
also was ist die gendergerechte Variante von Bankkaufmann, ich war mir jetzt klar, dass
man Bankkaufmann und Bankkauffrau sagen kann, aber wie macht man da ein Wort drauf, Bankkaufinnen
oder wie, das ergibt keinen Sinn, eigentlich ist mir das vollkommen wurscht, solang das
keiner von mir erwartet, das kann jeder machen wie er will, das kann jeder komplett machen
wie er will, ich bin ja eh ein Fan von freier Entfaltung und das sollen die einfach machen,
solang von mir keiner erwartet oder mir das irgendwie aufzwingen will, das klingt natürlich
auch sehr sinnvoll, was ich aber witzig finde, wenn es um negative Sachen geht, dann ist
das meistens in Ordnung, wenn das männlich ist, aber letztendlich juckt es mich nicht,
das ist ein Thema, ganz ehrlich, ich setze mich damit auch ungern auseinander öffentlich
oder generell noch ungern auseinander, weil da geht es zum größten Teil gar nicht mehr
darum eine rationale nachvollziehbare an der realen Welt orientierte Sache zu machen, sondern
nur um irgendwelche ideologischen Dinge durchzudrücken, von denen man sagt, keine Ahnung was das noch
für ein Bezug zur Realität hat, sondern wir fantasieren uns einfach zusammen, dass es
besser ist und es juckt mich nicht, es juckt mich nicht, ist mir egal, was hatte die 1
in der Uhr getan, das ist so eine Angewohnheit die ich habe, das kommt in dem Video erkläre
ich es ja auch, weil die Frage kommt total oft, ich habe mir irgendwann mal eine angewöhnte
1 in die Zwischenablage zu machen, ich glaube das kommt noch aus Zeiten wo ich ICQ und sowas
verwendet habe oder MMO Chats, dass ich nicht aus Versehen das falsche Copy Paste, deswegen
habe ich immer mal eine Zwischenablage überschrieben, ich habe in MMOs ab und zu mal das falsche
Copy Paste an die falschen Leute, das war immer peinlich, wenn du vor allem wenn es
derjenige ist, über den du gerade voll ablässt hast und dann Copy Paste die in die Messager,
ich habe keine Links in der Zwischenablage, ich habe meistens Texts in der Zwischenablage,
aber stell dir mal vor, du bist in dem MMO und chattest da irgendwie mit 5-6 Leuten gleichzeitig
und einer davon ist der übelste Depp der dir immer auf den Keks geht, aber in irgendeiner
Art und Weise musst du dich doch ganz gut mit ihm stellen, dann ist es schlecht wenn
du gerade einem anderen schreiben willst, alter der Kacknoob schreibt mich schon wieder an
und ich sende es ihm aus Versehen, ja wusste ich, habe ich hier übrigens ausgeschaltet,
weil Woop League, man weiß ja nie, der Depp ist Meister Gilden, ich muss zu sagen, ich
war in MMOs nur in Ultra Elite Hardcore 247 Kreiselgrinder Gilden, ich habe mich mit Noobs
in MMOs erst gar nicht abgegeben, nein ganz so schlimm war es nicht, ich war immer nur
in High-Level Elite PvP Gilds, keine Zeit mit Noobs da zu groupen, das ist eigentlich
total hängen geblieben, ich habe mir damals ja übelst was drauf eingebildet, weil Daok
8 vs 8 gespielt und sich übelst geil gefunden, dass man den halben Server geowned hat, was
nicht schwer war, weil 90% der Spieler richtige Kacknoobs waren, die du weg Aeen konntest
mit ein paar gut geskillten und gut equipten und gelevelten Chars, damals fand ich das
so geil, dass wir da mit 8 Leute 50 gekillt haben, da ging mir richtig einer drauf ab,
ich bin aber nicht mehr lange da, ich bin genau noch 4 Minuten da, ganz im Ernst, Passt
of Exile 2, ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass Diablo 4 auch nur ansatzweise da rankommt,
es ist schon lange nicht mehr so, dass Passt of Exile die Konkurrenz zu Diablo ist, mittlerweile
ist es so, Diablo ist die Konkurrenz zu Passt of Exile, die haben gezeigt, dass man es schaffen
kann, ein Game jahrelang am Leben zu halten, auch wenn, und das muss man da auch mal sagen,
auch wenn in letzter Zeit sehr viele hardcore Passt of Exile Fans pissed sind auf Crying
Gear Games, aber die haben es wirklich lange geschafft, dass die Fans gut auf sie zu sprechen
waren, also ich kenne kaum einen Hersteller, der ein Game gemacht hat und irgendwie 8 Jahre
oder so am Stück supportet hat und die Leute mochten den Hersteller, die haben es erst
die letzten 1-2 Jahre verkackt, nee Patrick, das sind nicht nur die Hardcore Leute, die
waren auch positiv immer Crying Gear Games gegenüber gestellt, weil die Hardcore Leute
sind ja auch das, die die ganzen 300€ Skin Packs und so kaufen, die müssen wohl irgendwas
an ihrer Kommunikation geändert haben, ich weiß es nicht, ich bin da nicht genug drin
in diesen ganzen Passt of Exile Zeug, keine Ahnung, aber mal ganz im Ernst, Passt of Exile
ist das, was sie schlagen müssen mit Diablo und nicht umgedreht, deswegen wenn ich drauf
tippen müsste, wenn ich mir angucke, was Blizzard die letzten Jahre immer so gebaut hat, wenn
ich mir dann angucke, was Grinding Gear Games gemacht hat, für mich ist klar, PoE 2 wird
es machen, vielleicht nicht der initiale Hype, der initiale Hype hat Diablo immer, aber langfristig
Passt of Exile 2 ganz klar, ja macht es, Sacred 1 mit A, das war wirklich gut, Sacred 2 fand
ich auch nicht so übel, Windows Updates, ja by the way, ich müsste jetzt, vielleicht
es ist 21h1, Diablo 2 Remastered, Diablo 2 ist ja auch ein Game, also du kannst eigentlich
kaum was verkacken, also das hat ja auch nicht die Komplexität von dem Warcraft 3, ich glaube,
man kann Diablo 2 gar nicht so richtig verkacken und ich wette, mit euch Blizzard schafft es
trotzdem irgendwie, dass es am Ende schlechter ist als das Original, ja ja, wie gesagt, möglich
ist es, möglich ist es, nee, Aktionshaus machen die nicht mehr, also sollten die wirklich
echt Geld schütten, Diablo 2 einbauen, das ist vorbei, nee, das glaube ich nicht, aber
ich glaube, sie werden es in irgendeiner Art und Weise anders verkacken, ich weiß noch
nicht wie, aber die schaffen es, die schaffen es irgendwie, Leute, es ist soweit, es ist
22h, wartet mal, wen hausten wir denn, ach komm mal, der Battlefield 3 Streamsor ist wieder
am Start, guck mal hier, der Battlefield 3 Streamsor, 3 in 30 Leute gucken da sogar zu
und guck mal, er spielt mit I-Lesbian-Support zusammen, komm den hausten wir, haust, zack,
nee er spielt nicht, Metro, was ist da los, klar ist das Metro, nee, Keg-Wade, was ist
das, das ist Bazaar, nee Sand-Crossing, Sand-Crossing ist das, Sand-Crossing ist das, ich Bazaar,
okay Leute, also bis denn, machts gut, CU.